help everyone
i am glad to present our project data
driven survey to map the relation
between oral microbiome and
neuropsychiatry disease
i'm dr priya from hyderabad this poster
depicts my whole project which includes
introduction
methods use results the data
visualization and analysis and
conclusion
i'll start off by explaining why this
project idea we choose in specific
so human body is colonized with
trillions of microorganism in various
parts of the body
like throat cut skin etc
ratio between the species can be totally
different from person to person
each individual microbiome is unique
like your fingerprint or bite mark
human and their microbiota have a mutual
relationship which benefit each other
but they create problems if the balance
between the colonies is gone
in a healthy adult body there are
approximately 10 times more bacteria
than human cells
the microbial community in our body
include members of hugely diverse array
of kingdoms and species
when does the microbiome enter into our
body
the uterus is totally sterile but as
soon as you're exposed
when you're born to millions of microbes
that immediately colonize your body
babies which are born vaginally are
covered with microbes living in their
mother's birth canal while babies born
by c-section are exposed to microbes on
skin
even where the baby is born and what it
is fed
will
affect the microbe composition
as they grow up they pick microbe from
the environment also
as an adult lot of things influence your
microbiome composition
like food you eat the illness you get
medications your prescribed the
workplace etc
oral microbiome is a community of
microbes that live within the oral
cavity locations like palatal region
tonsiller area throat
tongue
gingiva
teeth and supreme subgingival plaque
attached to the teeth etc so when
imbalance occur due to various
conditions like poor oral health or
serostomia which is dry mouth which
leads to dysbiosis which in turn can
release various metabolites and
inflammatory protein which leads to
inflammation which in turn leads to
changes in the brain function so from
the oral cavity
various pathways are available to reach
the brain like vascular system through
the blood brain barrier the olfactory
tract the perivascular space of brain
and the circumvention organs the
microbiome from the oral cavity enter
the gut and cause further changes in the
industrial layer as seen in the picture
during dysbiosis the tight junction get
loosened thinning of the mucosal layer
happen the cell count get depleted which
pairs the pathway for microbes to enter
the circulatory system which in turn
affects the brain health and individual
health there are various pathways how
microbes interact with the brain
first through the immune cells second
through metabolites and
neurotransmitters like serotonin
and the main way is through entry
nervous system
through the central nervous system by
the vagus nerve so the neuroactive
molecules from the gut
get transferred to the brain through the
vagus nerve directly
so in our project we are trying to
figure out how specific species of
microbes are affecting the brain and
causing neuropsychiatric symptoms and
how we can tailor the microbiome to
maximize mental health benefits
so here we are focusing on six major
neuropsychiatry disease like alzheimer's
autism schizophrenia major depressive
disorder adhd and bipolar disorder
neuropsychiatry disease is the third
most common
for disability adjusted life years
globally and
there is a growing concern about the
wave of neuropsychiatric burden during
this scuba 19 pandemic
some common neuropsychiatric
manifestation include delirium mild
cognitive impairment mood swing insomnia
and psychosis
so for this project we use this biome
data set to estimate the association
between oral microbiome attributable to
neuropsychiatric disorders
this database covers microbial
composition changes in different kinds
of disease
so the dataset include disease name
sample type post type microorganism type
methods used and the qualitative outcome
these are the keywords which were used
this table highlights how much data we
got for each disease and the number of
samples
which was involved in each disease
then we use
complex graph analytics
we try to answer the following question
using graph theory
so which organism is more influence in
each particular disease and all six
diseases together which organism is
least influence in each disease and all
disease together
which disease is influenced by microbes
less and more
from the complex graph we calculated
various indicators using mathematical
formulas like between a centrality
centrality of proximity eagan vector
centrality so this is one of the graph
produced from the data set
these are few screenshots of the results
which we got from our analysis the major
key findings are
autism spectrum disorder is influenced
by more microorganism bipolar is least
influenced by microorganism
lactobacillus species and saturated
species have influenced more disease in
this network
then way cellar species gaming or
species and pseudo monodacia species has
influenced less disease in this network
so we tried to got all the answers
through this graph analytics theory
the future direction of a project is by
doing further downstream analysis we can
understand the specific metabolites
genes
coenzymes involved in that particular
disease and can treat effectively so
hereby i conclude there is a huge
benefit of microbiome in precision
medicine
the ease of manipulation and delivery of
therapeutic aimed at modulating
microbiome function can be very
effective
the adoption of routine sampling
associated with wellness center visit to
primary care physician in combination
with human genome and other clinical
data which will enhance the decision
process around the treatment option very
effectively
these are the references used for our
project
thank you for this great opportunity